There's a
warning and a portrait
of Republican cowardice
from a former congresswoman
who says she witnessed it right up close.
CNN has new and exclusive details
from Liz Cheney.
His new book is titled Oath and Honor,
and it's due out next week.
But lo
and behold, CNN got a hold of a copy.
Cheney's chronicles various episodes
showing how Republicans
bent every
which way to try
to appease the former
president, Donald Trump.
Here to talk about it, former
congressman and January
six select committee member
Adam Kinzinger
and the reporter
who broke this CNN
exclusive special correspondent
Jamie Gangel.
I'm so glad that you're here.
I tell you, I want to like
take the book out of your hands and like,
oh, thank you.
I want to read it. Cover to cover.
I'll hold it right here for a second.
But she's not holding book in this.
How in back in this book at all.
Tell me about it. Absolutely. Night.
So Liz Cheney is painting
a scathing portrait
of her Republican colleagues of the party
for what she calls
she calls them enablers, collaborators.
She says they appeased him
and she talks about their cowardice.
I just want to read you
a couple of quotes from the book.
She says, quote,
Donald Trump cannot succeed alone
and they are enabling him.
I think what's important is
she has the receipts.
She names names.
The book is based on text messages,
emails, personal conversations, meetings.
And it's really filled with revelations
about what was going on
behind the scenes.
So she talks about her
relationship, her unlikely alliance
with Nancy Pelosi.
But here is an extraordinary scene
from the book.
It is January six.
It's the GOP cloak room.
And Republican Congressman
Mark Green of Tennessee
is signing his name to object
to electoral votes.
They all know, as she writes in the book,
that it's a farce
and she overhears him
say the following quote as he moved
down the line,
signing his name to the pieces of paper,
Green said,
sheepish, only to no one in particular.
The things we do for Orange Jesus.
Well, that's the new nickname,
the Orange Jesus.
Obviously talking about Donald Trump,
he's talking about Donald Trump.
So, you know, in public,
they're supporting him in private.
This is you're hearing
what they really say.
You know, in a way,
we suspected a new part of that
from their reporting over the years.
He behind the scenes
would talk about something
and then in front of the cameras.
But there's also this moment
that I think everyone wondered about,
and that was
when former speaker
Kevin McCarthy,
who was hoping to become
the speaker of the House.
Obviously, it was a short lived venture,
but about his trip to Mar a Lago
and this book talks about Liz
Cheney, his question to him
as to why he was in this picture,
why he went down there.
Here's the picture we're talking about.
What did she say?
So first of all,
when she saw that picture,
she thought it was a fake.
She couldn't believe it.
This is just three weeks
after January 6th,
and he secretly goes down to Mar a Lago.
And when he comes back,
she confronts him.
And this is the conversation
that they have.
Cheney says,
sorry.
Let me get it here.
Mar a Lago.
What the hell, Kevin?
Kevin McCarthy
says they're really worried.
Trump's not eating,
so they asked me to come see him.
Cheney. What?
You went to Mar a Lago
because Trump's not eating.
McCarthy.
Yeah, he's really depressed.
I seriously, Jamie, I mean, I
you really can't script this.
If this had been an actual show,
it would have jumped the shark,
as I say, a long time ago.
That's what
let me let me bring in here for a second
and think about this moment
for we bring in the former
Congressman Adam Kinzinger,
who lived this and saw this.
Is that seriously what his motivation
was for going down tomorrow?
No, no,
he was going
because in the three weeks
between January six, when for 15 minutes,
the Republicans
all said the right thing,
They condemned the January 6th attack.
They said Trump was responsible.
All of a sudden,
Kevin McCarthy can't raise money anymore.
Kevin McCarthy wants
to be speaker of the House.
And I'm sure
Congressman Kinzinger
can speak to this much better than I do.
But he goes running back to Trump
because he thinks he needs Trump's
help to get money and to become speaker.
Congressman Kinzinger,
we bring you in here because you know,
you have to wonder, knowing that
we've all seen how this all played out,
as in being the speaker of the House.
Was that photograph
and those moments actually worth it?
But you've lived this both on January six
and, of course,
your work on the committee.
When you're hearing all of this
from this soon to be released
book by your fellow congresswoman
and member of that same committee.
What is your reaction?
I mean, it's zero
surprise on any of this.
Like, I mean,
so you asked me, was it worth it?
Well, if you have no how do I say this?
Like somewhat professional.
If you have no moral center
and your whole goal is just to attain
some kind of a position,
which is Kevin McCarthy, then yeah,
it was worth it
because he became speaker
and he will forever
be known as Speaker Kevin McCarthy now.
Was it worth it for the country?
Was it worth it for the cost
to your own personal soul? I guess?
I don't think so,
because look, it's funny because,
you know,
as Jamie is talking about him
saying, well, you know, he's not eating.
First off,
the idea of like Kevin
going down there
and feeding Donald Trump.
And as matter of it's just blows me away.
You've got to be
I am too visual for that. Please.
I'm too visual for that right now.
I can't. Go ahead.
Let's.
Secondly, I also I know Kevin
well and I can I can hear him saying it
because what Kevin does
every time he talks to you,
he takes your side.
So when Liz calls him,
he thinks it's going to be good to say,
like he's depressed and not eating.
To live like Liz is going to care.
And then, like, to me it was basically,
well, you know, he's
I was down there fundraising
and they invited me over.
You're not going to say no
to the former president.
And I'm sure when some of the Freedom
Club members called him, he's like, Yeah,
because I'm all in on Donald Trump.
I mean, he doesn't
there's no, like, core to him.
The reality is,
I think if the speaker's race
had been four years away,
you would have seen Kevin McCarthy
do something different
because he could have thought about it
and said, over four years,
I may be able to take on this Trump base
and kind of get the party
back to the quote unquote normal.
Instead. And he's right.
He could not have done that in two years.
So he had to make a decision
for the country
or for the title of speaker.
And I got to tell you,
history will judge that.
Kevin McCarthy
I've said this since I guess
since the day it happened.
Kevin McCarthy is the guy,
the guy that resurrected Donald Trump.
Wow.
I mean, look,
you and
Liz Cheney,
I mean, you both want to turn the party
toward a different future,
likely for that very reason
and the resurrection, so to speak, of
what was the name of one of the members
talking in the book, The Orange Jesus?
I think it was.
We are seeing some high donors
try and do the same thing
with the Koch brothers.
Obviously, now they're backing
Nikki Haley, not Trump.
But we're not saying this either.
We're just going to talk about
more in my next segment.
But do you think this this influx of cash
to different candidates
will make a difference
and maybe suppress
that so-called resurrection?
Well, it always
makes a difference because, again,
anything is just momentum.
So giving people permission right now
and this is what's weird
when you have like
kind of the almost cult structure
that exists in the GOP
with around Donald Trump.
Because, listen,
you know, Liz is stories
about hearing people
say something different.
Then I had
people come up to me on the floor
all the time
and tell me thank you for doing
the January six committee stuff
and then saying,
I mean, I can't do it
because of my district.
I'm like, Have you seen my district?
So all of these things
give people a permission
structure to walk away.
And we're kind of at that point.
I mean, Trump's got to lose a lot to lose
the primary, let's be clear.
So I think, you know,
probably smart money's on Donald
Trump gets it.
But you look at Nikki Haley,
you look at Chris
Christie surging in New Hampshire,
I think there is a possibility,
especially if Donald Trump ends
up going to trial in the spring,
that it's somebody else.
But again, if I was in
Vegas playing
Vegas, odds, I'd probably
I probably wouldn't
put any money on that.
Well,
I mean, Jamie, the Coke team has, what,
$70 million war chest?
I don't know about smart money,
but a lot of money comes into this.
But I want to ask you
about the name of the title of the book.
It's called Oath and Honor.
And I am going to steal this from you.
I'm not giving it back.
Sorry about that.
It's a memoir and a warning
and I don't spoil it for me
or the audience,
but what's the nature of the warning?
Look,
I think this is taking Liz
Cheney has said
that Donald Trump
is the most dangerous person
to have ever been in the Oval Office.
And she concludes the book,
and I'm not giving it away.
There's more.
But with really this chilling warning,
and that is
that if he's allowed
to be president again,
the checks and balances of our country
will not hold this
time, that
there will not be any guardrails.
And it's really a call to action,
not just Republicans,
Democrats, independents
and Republicans to come together
and make sure he's never president again.
Well, I may flip through the pages
and figure out Adam Kinzinger,
Jamie Gangel,
to see if there's an announcement
from the former
congresswoman, Liz Cheney.
I'm not saying it's in there,
but I'm curious to see if
maybe she has somebody else in mind
that she'd like to run
and if it has her own last name.
Thank you, both of you,
for joining me tonight.